well
the metropolitan police are
investigating a murder near
flamingo and the avenue and hope that such
health to cristian cancers officers
responded to a
truck accident around
11 pm on monday and there they
found a man with a wound  de bala the
authorities are on the trail of the
suspects and obtained exclusive video
of 20-year-old george rubí being arrested
within movies el de sant and correr,
20, are accused of two
armed robberies that ended the lives
of two people  they were arrested
approximately six hours from when
the first incident occurred both are
scheduled to appear in court Tuesday later house
was arrested Monday and faces
charges for you while after
police found him asleep inside his
car in the hotel parking lot and
chrome casino this happened two months after
the arrest of henry valdez accused of
driving while intoxicated and causing the
accident  te that stole his chinese life
within 23 years after his
vehicle started and there is high
demand for kobe 19 tests here in
the valley for the second day in a row
several hours at a site
located in journal and the
health district  southern nevada opened more
testing sites around the county for a
complete list visit our page and
inés now dotcom in the
spanish section and we continue with low
temperatures around here in the valley
we will have a sunny day with
temperatures reaching 55 degrees
we will notice an increase  In the temperatures,
since they will rise to 60 degrees for
the rest of the week, do not trust yourself,
the minimum will be in the 30s, I am
Cristian, the consul's house, but
informative from News Now in Spanish, good
day
[Music]